Rafael: Hello, my name as Rafael Ramirez and
I'm a Senior Research Fellow at Oxford in
Futures, I also chair the Global Agenda Council
on Strategic Foresight and I'm there with
my colleague John from Singapore. I've been
asked to comment on whether China will pull
us out of the economic crisis. Part of the
problem is, who is us? Certainly in China
they don't seem to have very much of an economic
crisis. I just landed here from India, wherein
the growth is going off [ INAUDIBLE ]. So
if us is Europe, then we don't seem to count
for very much. If us is the West, we do seem
to count for something. I found it impossible
to fly directly from Mumbai to Beijing, no
direct flights. So the flights from Mumbai
and from Beijing seem to go to the west, but
not to each other. And I think one of the
big challenges is the kind of relationships
that China and India have in relationship
to each other. There will be more people in
India in 2019 than China if current trends
continue. So India will matter as much as
as China in the mid- to long-term. And I know
from a scenario planning that it is very difficult
to think about the long-term when you are
caught in the midst of a termoil as we have
been in in Europe and the United States in
the last 24 and 12 months. I think that the
question is what kind of role will China and
India have in relation to each other and how
that plays out going forward and we should
think in 10 and 20 year terms horizons rather
than three year term horizon.